et pour parler des voeux du président à
la presse nous sommes avec gilles
casanova consultant en stratégie et
communication gilles casanova bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
directe sur rt france alors on le disait
l'année dernière le président emmanuel
macron avait boudé l'exercice des voeux
avec les journalistes
pas cette année en pleine crise sociale
comme on peut le comprendre
on peut imaginer que il a attendu sept
mois pour se doter d'un nouveau
conseiller en communication et que son
nouveau conseiller en communication je
lui ai dit on ne peut pas ne pas
présenter ses voeux à la presse
ça ne se fait pas ça n'existe pas et
donc il a dû me prendre conscience de ce
fait probablement sur l'encouragement de
son entourage mais je ne crois pas que
ça lui fasse plaisir
qu'est ce qui explique justement ces
relations difficiles en peut lire entre
le président emmanuel macron et les
journalistes quel est le regard du
président sur cette profession selon
rouge alors il ya quelque chose qu'il
faut comprendre qui n'est pas simple un
politique
il voudrait que les journalistes disent
exactement ce qu'il a envie d'entendre
c'est à dire qu'il voudrait que les
journalistes à the eye dans le détail de
ce qu'il fait dans le détail de tout ce
qu'il a réussi et laisse de côté tout ce
qui n'a pas marché et les journalistes
même lorsqu'ils soutiennent un homme
politique comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
80% des journalistes sont
personnellement en accord avec emmanuel
macron 100 % des propriétaires de 94% de
la presse française sont les soutiens de
premier plan d' emmanuel macron mais
cependant ils ne peuvent pas organiser
la presse comme le culte de la
personnalité des années 30
ils sont obligés de laisser un espace
pour la critique ils sont obligés de
laisser un espace pour des révélations
sur ce que fait tel ou tel ministre on
sait que on n'a jamais eu depuis le
début de la vème république autant de
ministres oblige
quitter le gouvernement donc le
politique il a tendance plus il est
jeune et plus il est né expérimenté à
vouloir que la presse disent constamment
du bien emmanuel macron il s'en est
flatté n'a même jamais était conseiller
municipal
c'est à dire qu'il n'a jamais été
confronté au fait que la presse même
quand elle vous aime bien est obligé de
dire du bien et du mal tout le dosage
entre le bien et le mal
montrera la distance entre vos soutiens
et ceux qui vous apprécie moins et est
ce que le fait qu'il donne aujourd'hui
ses voeux à la presse montre aussi que
le président a besoin des médias
également pour pour se faire entendre et
comprendre il veut se faire comprendre
sur la réforme des retraites il a donc
besoin des médias il a d'abord fait
passer des lois anti fait news qui met
les journalistes sous le regard des
juges comme des gens qui seraient
spontanément des menteurs donc il n'est
pas en très bonne posture avec même
s'ils soutiennent sa politique
il commence à se détacher de sa personne
ensuite il a mis en place une sorte de
conseil de
de père fouettard sur les journalistes
auxquels beaucoup de journalistes ont
refusé de participer et non des moindres
de ses soutiens dans c'est à dire des
gens qui l'ont soutenu politiquement
depuis le début donc il a fait
suffisamment de bévues vis-à-vis des
journalistes des journalistes qui le
soutiennent parce que les journalistes
qui sont dans des titres qui sont plus
réservées voire opposées il n'en a cure
ils sont minoritaires et c'est pas son
problème du tout mais les journalistes
qui le soutiennent il a fait
suffisamment de bévues pour essayer de
venir leur dire que finalement il les
aime bien
il ya aussi le cas on l'entendait de
faire de notre antenne de rtl france pas
seulement spoutnik également d'autres
médias russes le président entretient
une méfiance envers envers ces médias et
puis de l'autre côté il ya un certain
réchauffement finalement avec la russie
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
méfiance du président envers ces médias
russes je crois que il s'agit de
d'empêcher l'institutionnalisation de
médias qui ne tiennent pas le discours
officiel de ce que marcel gauchet
appelle le parti les médias et ça c'est
indépendamment des rapports avec une
puissance étrangère qui pourrait être le
principal actionnaire du média
la question clé c'est de maintenir la
puissance du parti des médias qui a mis
tout son poids en sa faveur dans la
balance
et donc il faut pas le laisser entamer
par le fait qu'on pourrait tolérer de
dire autre chose
merci beaucoup gilles cazade avoué
d'avoir partagé votre expertise en
direct sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en stratégie et
communication
merci